it's pouring for
I feel so close to you
have you found for me I let you go but I
don't know how
and I know
it's just another night but if I were
you again
and I remember way did waste
so thank you start here we go guys so
much for sitting down with us of course
thank you for having me Morris so I'm
just kind of to start off I was reading
reading up on you and it was mentioned
that at first you were really anxious to
perform in front of people and that kind
of stopped you from pursuing music at
first what made you decide to start your
own YouTube channel okay interesting
story I am i huh I had a boyfriend um
it's been a year now that we well a year
ago I had a boyfriend and his sister
actually she's saying and she was a kind
of kind of person that would like sing
in front of people but like do it a lot
and do it loud so that you knew she was
singing look at me and so I was just
like man like I can sing like I know I
can sing I want people to know that
about me it's like this talent that I
was just too scared to show people so I
decided to make a u2 cover so I got on
my computer and just saying to this
karaoke track and then all the sudden
people from my school just started like
they would see it and I'd be like you
sing I was like I guess that yeah and
then it just kind of took off from there
I guess need so were you anxious the
first time you put this video up how are
you feeling oh my gosh yeah I did like
17 cakes and it was I was nervous but
like it was a lot easier for me to just
do it to my computer even though like
technically more people we're going to
see it like a bigger audience because it
was going on the internet I like it was
just a lot easier for me to just do it
in my room by myself on the computer but
I was still nervous yeah needs so since
then you join the tyler ward contest and
then you collaborated with him and
you've collaborated with so many other
PA all this your channel really grown
and evolved since these first videos
well let's see I mean Tyler helped a lot
he gave me kind of like a platform to go
and do things myself and so that I could
create a fan base that was
an alex g fanbase not just like Oh Alex
gene tyler ward sort of thing because i
wanted to be an independent artist and i
wanted to do my own thing so i guess
like what happened was we were I was
relying on him a lot to help me with
things and he was helping me and we
collabed but it got to the point where
he'd get really busy and I was like what
do I do like I don't want to just end
this music thing so I found ways to do
it myself basically so I like learned
how to edit video um I came out here to
LA and started working with other
producers and stuff like that so
basically like he helped me but then I
just kind of took off on my own and grew
my channel by like I guess just doing
the cover thing and I'm getting up
getting to put originals outside so for
a lot of both I've read that like both
of your covers and your original stuff
you really like writing about things
that you're super passionate about it's
not something that you really focus on
when you're picking a song or when
you're writing sewing um yeah well for
writing a song it's very hard for me to
write if it's not something that's like
dear to my heart or like something that
I'm going through that I'm like you said
passionate about or just having a hard
time like emotionally with so it's much
easier when it like can come straight
from the heart straight from the mind
instead of just like well what would
this person say they were going through
this situation and yada yada yada but
and then for cover is I just it doesn't
have to do so much with like what I'm
passionate about just I guess if I like
this song and if it's a big song it's
like more of like the business side of
things with covers and then originals is
more like focus on my myself as an
artist no no but how do you kind of keep
like these covers unique so that when
people they feel like they're getting
something different from your cupboard
yeah as opposed to everyone else um you
just have to change the cover basically
like say it's a pop hit and I'll make it
into like a slow acoustic
Khalid if you just like make it as
unique as you can show a little bit of
artistry into it I think they'll
appreciate that a lot of them like
they'll download it and stuff like that
and instead of just being a singer and
makes you more like an artist hmm so
yeah what made you decide you wanted to
pick up guitar cuz you learned it super
quickly like I guess I did um basically
I was going to school in college and my
roommate didn't really talk to me ever
so I was like what am I gonna do didn't
hear in my room so I decided to pick a
guitar cuz I'd always wanted to learn I
was just too impatient for as long as I
can remember and so my mom like gave me
her old guitar and I brought it up to
school and literally just played Taylor
Swift songs like over and over again
until I learned it and I'd never took
lessons or anything I just tried to
learn by myself so yeah I learned by
myself and I've been doing it for like
two years did that make your roommate
love you more when she heard taylor
swift eight hours a day never she just
no not not really not really that's okay
when did you make the big decision that
you decided you know college isn't for
me I want to pursue this as an artist
what was the feedback you got from
people was it kind of like a huge leap
of faith um the end of the the end of
the first year my college experience as
waiting to hear back from Tyler if I was
gonna go join him on the American tour
at the end of the year and so I was
thinking like if I get to go on that
tour like that's gonna be five weeks in
I if I get to go on that I don't want to
go back to school I kind of just want to
focus on music and so that's basically
he basically said like I think you're
ready let's do it and I was like okay so
I from then like I just was put all my
focus into my channel and music and
performing and
man like and I never thought that that
was ever gonna happen for me because I
was always like really focused on school
and my parents were just like go for it
like sweet we don't pay for your college
anymore I was like yeah I guess so and
then like had a boyfriend at the time
too and he he wasn't too thrilled about
it I guess because well that's a long
story but but um most of the people
around me in my life were very
supportive well what are you working on
right now while you're out here in LA
and also when you go back to Colorado
yeah right now I'm working on writing
sessions and that's new because I've
only written with myself and like Tyler
so I get to write with some really
talented people and I'm just doing a lot
of recording and like filming and trying
to get my youtube channel going again
mm-hmm because I haven't been able to
since I've been on tour so yeah how was
tour tour was awesome it was like Europe
is like fairytale wonderland it's it's
crazy it's just another world and then
but it went by so fast and I think like
by the end of it I kind of got sick of
like the weird German meets better than
you but other than that like it's an
amazing experience perform live it just
always is and especially with like a
crowd is so engaging and who like knows
who you are it was just is really is
really
and a good experience for me because I
need more experience performing live so
how's it been working with a management
company like has it been easier to
network that way or would you recommend
it for other people yeah um at first he
was a little difficult more difficult
for me because of what I do and like I
was one of the only people in big frame
who to music so there wasn't a lot of
like brand dealing I could do but there
was a lot of like networking and other
people to like do stuff with another
things to get involved in that I would
have never known if I never signed with
them so definitely recommend it um it's
good it's a good way to like get
opportunities like I said and just meet
everybody on YouTube it's good it's an
definitely a positive experience so when
you think back over the craziness of the
last couple years what are some of the
best parts about this entire journey I
feel like I'm just a completely
different person now than I was like
before I was doing music in the
beginning of this music thing I've like
learned so much just as my like about
myself and about music like I didn't
know anything and it's just cool now
knowing that I can be so independent and
like do like do something that I'm
passionate about it's the coolest thing
ever for it to do something you're
passionate about for a living and I've
just learned like to be to be I again
like more dependent I've grown up a lot
had to deal with things on my own and um
yeah I just it's it's been a real
blessing really and I venom it's some of
the best friends I've ever had so that's
cool they're kind of like family and
they're all dudes so it's cool but yeah
yeah I guess that's the coolest thing
what do you hope that people take away
from your music I just hope that they
can hear the realness I fry always want
to be genuine in my lyrics I never want
to just write a song to write a catchy
song
like I want them to like kind of get a
part a piece of me in each song that i
right I think that's important I think
you'll have like long-lasting fans that
way you kid you um nothing I can really
think of now but there's there's a lot
of really exciting things that's gonna
be happening for my career but I don't
really know what it is but I can I can
feel it I can feel it's gonna be big
that's exciting i'm excited to follow it
yeah thanks oh thank you so much for yes
yeah I think you should go for the
tattoo
still
thank you
ah